well it's always a little hard to know  exactly how long it takes me to write  something because I'm constantly writing  and then I don't know what pieces will  become something but what I do know is  that I I have a draft  a very long draft so at least  at least a couple years  um so you honed it down how long is a  long draft look  um that was about 350 pages I I mean it  was and I mean some of the scenes didn't  go anywhere it wasn't like it wasn't  like 350 pages of something that was  narratively cohesive it was 350 pages of  stuff that then I  um kind of looked at and figured out  what felt essential and what felt like  the core of the story to me yeah  um and it's some I don't really decide  what a core of a story is before I write  I I write to figure out what the story  is and